let's talk about Black Monday
this show is terrific III think I get
the sense you really love being this
character I think you that's the sense I
get is that it's fun because you are
your you are flawed which I in glorious
ways in glorious ways I can tell
watching you do this it's like oh yeah
Dawn's having fun he's having a good
time with this yeah and I have a great
time with my cast mates and and the
writers room and and our producers and
the directors that were able to bring in
we've had a lot of a lot of great
experience with with all of these every
aspect of the show from in front and
behind the camera and everybody really
shows up yeah work our because we're
trying we're making this show in five
days you know each ups five days which
is bananas you know it's it's it's not
enough time I think that kind of plays
into sort of the dynamics of the show it
feels frenetic it feels like you know
everybody's on coke experiencing it it
just feels like this you know crazy
energy in a bottle and it's just and
it's fun and I think if we didn't have
the cast that we had and we didn't have
you know the ability to just run and gun
I think it would be a turgid experience
but because we're all like there and can
really play off of each other and have a
lot of fun with each other I think it
just pops I mean yeah I doing a show
like this in five days and there are
probably a lot of people watching they
don't understand what you what what kind
of timeline usually exists for a show
like this they could spend me five days
is ridiculous but it does probably help
all of you feel like you're in the
trenches yeah and and and help and yeah
you it helps you feel and look coked up
[Laughter]
there's never there's been countless
times when we've each had to pull each
other out of the fire you know and
others back in a way that really makes
you bond and I you know I feel really
close with all those guys and we spend
time away from the set before you know
Rona was on the stroll we did yeah
so it's it's really nice to have a group
of people that you feel you have a great
time showing up and if you're going to
be in the trenches you want to be
intentions with these days you have a
very different look this season I was
looking at this picture this morning and
that is fantastic
that is a fantastic look and maybe maybe
the answer for me I don't think you
should knock it until you try it walk
around a little bit see what the
feedback is play with it see I want to
try that look and you know that would be
I think I think I could pull it off
definitely I would get a lot of
attention you know I want to ask you I
know your character plays bass this
season is that something are you playing
the bass these days is like are you
doing the method thing of I'm gonna
learn the bass or are you saying I can
fake this let's just fake it well no it
was something that I think the writers
put in because I would always go back to
my room you know between shots and you
know between scenes and I'm always had a
bass with me oh so that's that's they're
taking that from you yeah firing they're
borrowing Don Cheadle's
okay I that makes sense now okay they're
going oh you can do that well let's try
to figure out a way to stick it in the
show and make fun of it and I was like
that's cool so no it's not they saw you
doing something that brings you joy and
they said make that part of your
character and everyone laughs at him
yeah cool you actually making me rethink
my whole experience on the show I was
trying not to go there but we've pierced
the veil so yeah they're not cool people
now that I think about it they're not
cool at all no no no I'll talk to them
I'm okay that's not gonna do anything I
won't talk